Trascrizione: Alberto Pagani
Revisore: Elena Montrasio
L'evoluzione è il campo della scienza
che forse racconta più storie
di tutti gli altri.
Racconta un sacco di storie:
solo che a differenza dei miti,
e delle narrazioni
che raccontiamo ai bimbi
noi cerchiamo di ricostruirle
attraverso delle prove,
delle evidenze, degli indizi.
Un po' come Sherlock Holmes.
Le storie però, lo sappiamo,
sono scivolose,
hanno dei pro e dei contro.
Ci possono affascinare,
ma ci possono anche ingannare:
ci possono raccontare
delle ricostruzioni false.
Molti anni fa un mio collega,
molto più illustre di me,
si chiamava J. B. S. Haldane,
è stato uno dei padri
della genetica delle popolazioni,
si trovava in un salotto
ad Oxford molto formale,
con presenti teologi,
signore e principesse.
E una di queste,
a un certo punto, gli chiese:
"Senta Professore,
ma se lei dovesse
immaginarsi il Creatore,
che cosa vedrebbe?
Come se lo immagina? "
Era una domanda un po' tendenziosa
perché Haldane era noto
per essere ateo, miscredente, comunista.
Le aveva addosso tutte, in Inghilterra,
soprattutto in quell'epoca.
E Haldane rispose:
"Guardi signora, non lo so.
Però, se dovessi immaginarmi il Creatore,
penso che egli abbia
una smodata passione per i coleotteri".
Cosa voleva dire Haldane?
Voleva dire che se noi guardiamo
la terra, e la biodiversità,
dal punto di vista di un evoluzionista,
la prima cosa che notiamo
è che noi siamo
alla periferia dell'impero,
noi non siamo al centro di questa storia.
Siamo una delle tante, meravigliose specie
prodotte dalla storia naturale.
La storia che vi racconto
adesso, brevemente,
è frutto di ricerche recentissime.
Quindi vi racconto cose
che abbiamo scoperto da pochi mesi,
e che sconvolgono decisamente
il nostro modo di raccontare
l'evoluzione umana.
È la storia di una
delusione, tutto sommato;
ma una delusione costruttiva,
una delusione che ci fa bene,
che ci fa pensare,
che rimette in moto le grandi domande
che la scienza è capace di sollevare.
Da dove veniamo? Perché?
Cosa ci facciamo qua?
Qual è il posto dell'uomo nella natura?
L'inizio della storia
è in questa immagine
che vedete alle mie spalle.
È una pagina affascinante, misteriosa,
scritta da Charles Darwin stesso,
risale al luglio del 1837.
Se vi ricordate le date,
vuol dire che era giovanissimo:
era nato nel 1809,
non aveva ancora 30 anni.
Era appena tornato
da un viaggio meraviglioso
in giro per il mondo,
che abbiamo studiato tutti,
durato cinque anni.
Torna nel '36,
e appena tornato inizia a scrivere
questi taccuini privati, privatissimi.
Così segreti che saranno, praticamente,
l'unico scritto darwiniano
che lui deciderà di non pubblicare mai.
Dirà proprio:
"Mi raccomando, non diffondete mai
quello che ho scritto da ragazzo
appena tornato da questo viaggio".
In una di queste pagine
c'è questo diagramma bellissimo
che lui chiama "The Tree of Life",
l'albero della vita.
E scrive, vedete "I think", io penso che:
e per la prima volta scrive a se stesso,
perché sta parlando a sé,
quello che ha capito dell'evoluzione.
Cioè che l'evoluzione è un albero.
E come un albero ha un fusto,
cioè gli antenati comuni,
e poi ha delle ramificazioni,
le specie che si diversificano
nel corso del tempo
e poi si estinguono,
che si moltiplicano e così via.
Una storia interessante,
una storia plurale,
fatta di tante specie diverse.
Perché vi racconto una storia
che in realtà è una delusione?
Perché quando poi siamo andati
ad applicare questa idea darwiniana -
già nel '37,
poi lui diventa famoso, pubblicherà
"L'origine delle specie" 20 anni dopo -
quando abbiamo trattato
l'evoluzione umana,
stranamente gli scienziati stessi
hanno fatto un'eccezione.
E dico gli scienziati stessi,
non persone esterne alla scienza
o degli avversari dell'evoluzione;
ma se guardate, per esempio,
come Thomas H. Huxley
ricostruiva l'evoluzione umana,
vedete che è molto diversa
dall'albero che vi ho fatto vedere prima.
Quella di prima era una storia
di diversità, di molteplicità,
di convivenza di specie diverse.
Questa è una storia molto diversa,
in cui c'è una sola specie per volta,
si procede in modo lineare.
Questa è una grande storia di progresso.
È quella che un mio collega,
che è stato molto importante
nella mia formazione,
si chiamava Stephen Jay Gould,
definiva "la nostra grande illusione".
L'illusione è che Homo Sapiens -
che è sempre messo in fondo,
all'estrema destra
e rappresenta il culmine dell'evoluzione -
l'illusione che la Storia dovesse,
necessariamente, portare fino a noi.
Sicuramente questa è un'immagine
molto familiare per tutti noi.
La troviamo sempre scritta
sui giornali, in televisione,
l'abbiamo vista citata tante volte.
Quello che abbiamo scoperto di recente
è che questa eccezione non vale.
È caduta, l'abbiamo messa in discussione.
L'evoluzione umana non è
andata affatto in questo modo.
Vi faccio vedere altre alternative
a questa immagine,
che viene usata in pubblicità,
viene usata ovunque.
La mia preferita
è quella in alto a destra,
che è comparsa su una rivista femminista
e mette a confronto
l'evoluzione del maschio,
molto lenta e graduale ma progressiva;
e quella della femmina,
stranamente molto stabile.
Ma la trovate in tutte le salse,
questa immagine.
È una sorta di grande icona.
Un'iconografia.
Anche oggi, quando noi pubblichiamo
articoli riguardanti l'evoluzione umana,
che vadano sui giornali,
ci mettono sempre questa immagine.
A me è capitato anche di recente.
La prima riga del mio articolo era:
"Non esistono anelli mancanti
nell'evoluzione"
e immediatamente
mi hanno messo quest'immagine,
con gli anelli mancanti.
Quindi è qualcosa di molto potente,
di profondamente radicato
nella nostra mente.
La versione decisamente che io scelgo
come la migliore in assoluto al mondo
è questa, che è stata
proposta nei Simpson,
dove l'evoluzione culmina,
inesorabilmente e meravigliosamente,
in Homersapiens,
che vedete all'estrema destra.
Perché è molto strana questa eccezione?
Perché mentre noi continuavamo
a tenere in piedi
questa grande iconografia della speranza,
gli scienziati andavano avanti
e ricostruivano le storie evolutive,
le storie naturali delle specie,
in un modo molto diverso.
Questa è un'immagine
meno decifrabile delle precedenti,
ma è meravigliosa.
Vi dico solo una cosa:
io penso che se un extraterrestre
dovesse cadere sulla Terra, fra un po',
e noi dovessimo raccontargli
una delle grandi conquiste
della scienza e del sapere -
ci sarebbe la teoria della relatività,
un sacco di scoperte in ambito fisico;
ma io gli farei vedere questa immagine.
E gli direi: guarda, qui c'è
la specie Homo Sapiens,
che grazie alla scienza
è riuscita a mettere insieme,
a ricostruire l'albero della vita.
Cioè a capire la parentela
tra tutti gli esseri viventi;
ma proprio tutti, dal battere
fino all'animale più complesso,
fino al giaguaro, alla giraffa,
agli esseri umani che hanno abitato
e che abitano questo pianeta.
Questo albero della vita mette insieme
tutti i viventi che noi conosciamo".
E vedete che è un albero,
che è ramificato, ci sono tante specie.
E se volete trovarvi,
è estremamente complicato
perché noi siamo qua,
siamo gli animali dentro qua
e tra l'altro siamo un po' più vicini
ai funghi che non alle piante,
anche questa cosa non ci piace tanto.
E dentro gli animali dovete fare
un ramoscello di un ramoscello
di un ramoscello, per nove volte
prima di trovare Homo Sapiens.
Quindi siamo alla periferia
dell'impero della biodiversità,
come aveva detto Haldane
con quella battuta spiritosa
per scandalizzare la signora.
La stessa cosa se ci avviciniamo
alla nostra storia più particolare,
alla nostra famiglia:
troviamo lo stesso schema, vedete?
Questo non voglio raccontarvelo
perché è un po' tecnico,
ma se guardate questa immagine
noi siamo qui, noi siamo questa specie,
siamo dentro questo genere,
che è il genere Homo.
Se guardate alle vostre spalle,
trovate una storia
di grandi ramificazioni come queste.
Quindi trovate
un cespuglio, non una scala.
Non trovate una linearità,
trovate una molteplicità.
E la cosa interessante,
per esempio in schemi come questi,
è che in qualsiasi momento
tiriate una linea del tempo -
immaginatevi di avere
una macchina del tempo,
scegliete un'epoca qualsiasi,
per esempio 10 milioni di anni fa,
tirate la linea,
scoprite che in qualsiasi momento
della storia evolutiva
c'erano tante specie diverse
contemporaneamente.
Chi più, chi meno, cugina delle altre.
E qui vedete, se partite dall'oggi,
che l'Homo ha un antenato
in comune con lo scimpanzé
vissuto all'incirca sei, sette
milioni di anni fa,
e andando più indietro ne ha uno
con i gorilla, gli oranghi, i gibboni
e con tutto il resto del vivente.
Quindi un'immagine
molto sintetica, molto potente.
Perché è entrata in crisi
questa immagine così potente
dell'evoluzione?
Come capita spesso nella scienza,
c'è un po' d'inerzia,
le idee nuove a volte
fanno un po' fatica a entrare;
poi però vengono sommerse dalle anomalie.
Non funzionava, quel modello;
e alla fine, con molta fatica,
l'abbiamo abbandonato.
Questa è una scoperta
bellissima, fatta nel 2009.
Pensate che ha conquistato
ben due copertine di Science,
data l'importanza della scoperta.
La scoperta più importante del 2009
è un nostro possibile antenato,
e si chiama Ardi, Ardipithecus.
Se lo guardate un po', vedete che è un mix
di caratteri moderni
e di caratteri arcaici.
È un po' uno scimmione, lo si vede
dagli arti superiori così lunghi,
dall'alluce divaricato;
però è perfettamente bipede.
Ha la faccia piatta -
e quindi è un mix di caratteri.
La cosa interessante che abbiamo scoperto
è che questo nostro antenato
non è stato all'inizio di tutta la storia,
ma ha vissuto insieme con tanti altri.
Guardate, questo è un esempio
abbastanza incredibile;
questa è una sola vallata dell'Etiopia.
Noi - anche noi Sapiens
siamo nati da quelle parti lì,
in una di quelle vallate.
E in una sola di queste vallate
c'erano, addirittura,
tre generi umani differenti
che sono indicati con i colori diversi.
E non succede mai che sparisce uno
e viene sostituito da un altro.
Quello che succede
è che convivono insieme,
in un modo cespuglioso.
Qualcuno si estingue,
qualche specie nuova nasce
e si crea quell'immagine complicata,
e interessante, dell'evoluzione
che ci riguarda anche direttamente.
Ecco, questo è il modo in cui noi oggi,
insieme con i miei colleghi,
ricostruiamo l'evoluzione umana.
Vedete? il tempo scorre
dal basso verso l'alto.
È un vero e proprio cespuglio.
Vedete che da quando c'è stato
l'antenato comune tra noi e gli scimpanzé,
ci sono stati tra noi e loro
quasi 20, forse addirittura 22,
c'è chi dice 25 specie diverse.
Altro che la scala lineare.
È molto più complicato:
un sacco di specie diverse.
Anche qua, in qualsiasi momento
voi tiriate una linea,
trovate un sacco
di specie contemporaneamente.
La cosa che abbiamo scoperto
di recente, nell'ultimo anno e mezzo,
e che ci ha un po' sconvolto
perché non ce l'aspettavamo,
è che questa storia riguarda
anche i tempi recentissimi.
Se voi guardate dentro qua,
Homo sapiens è in alto a destra
e noi siamo l'ultimo
ramoscello, questo qua.
Qua è l'oggi, il presente.
Se voi andate indietro pochissimo tempo,
anche solo 40,50 mila anni,
scoprite che sulla Terra
esistevano altre specie umane.
Quello che abbiamo scoperto, di recente,
è che fino a 30, 35,
massimo 40 mila anni fa,
pensate, sulla Terra esistevano
cinque specie umane contemporaneamente.
Che è una cosa che facciamo
quasi fatica ad immaginare:
cinque specie umane.
Se un extraterrestre
fosse caduto 40.000 anni fa,
avrebbe visto circolare sulla Terra
noi Sapiens, un po' dappertutto,
e altre quattro forme umane.
Questo apre un sacco di interrogativi,
naturalmente molto importanti
e anche intriganti.
Questa è una delle ultime scoperte,
fatta in Indonesia,
su una piccola isola, Flores.
Abbiamo trovato: cicogne
alte un metro e ottanta;
topi lunghi un metro
e mezzo, coda compresa;
e Hominini piccoli,
che non superavano
quasi mai un metro.
Questo è un nostro parente,
un nostro cugino
scoperto pochi anni fa su quest'isola.
È rimasto bloccato su quell'isola
per centinaia di migliaia anni.
Ed è diventato piccolo.
Questo è un meccanismo evolutivo
che si chiama nanismo insulare,
e succede spesso.
È successo anche in Italia.
Sapete che in Sicilia
c'erano gli elefanti nani,
che erano grandi come un cane
di grandi dimensioni;
in Sardegna c'erano i mammut, nani.
Questo perché,
quando specie a sangue caldo
di grandi dimensioni
rimangono bloccate sulle isole,
conviene loro, per selezione naturale,
diventare più piccoli.
Però questa è la prima volta
che, incredibilmente,
vediamo questa cosa succedere
in una specie umana.
Ma il fatto ancora più sconvolgente,
tant'è che ci abbiamo messo qualche anno
prima di accettarlo davvero,
e rassegnarci all'evidenza,
è che questo Homino qua,
chiamato subito "Hobbit Man"
dagli scienziati,
l'Hobbit Man su quell'isola, di Flores,
è andato avanti, è sopravvissuto
fino a 12.000 anni fa, l'altro ieri.
Praticamente noi tutti, a scuola,
abbiamo studiato gli Egizi, i Sumeri,
le civiltà della scrittura, le piramidi.
Prendete le piramidi,
andate indietro qualche migliaio di anni,
e sulla Terra esisteva
un'altra specie umana nostra cugina,
con la quale noi abbiamo vissuto
e con la quale ci siamo incontrati, pure.
Perché noi siamo passati, da quell'isola.
Lo sappiamo perché i Sapiens
sono arrivati in Australia
molto tempo prima
che questa si estinguesse.
Quindi sappiamo, anche,
che li abbiamo incontrati,
e che ci siamo visti.
Ma incontri ravvicinati
di tipo preistorico
ce ne sono stati
ancora di più sconvolgenti.
Questa è l'ultima scoperta,
vedete che il paper
è dell'aprile del 2010:
per farla breve, in Asia è stata scoperta,
in questa grotta, sui monti Altai
nella Siberia meridionale,
un'altra specie umana
che non ci aspettavamo esistesse.
Noi sapevamo che in questa grotta,
la grotta di Denisova,
ci stavano già due specie: noi Sapiens,
già da 40-50 mila anni fa, e i Neandertal.
Famosissimi, li abbiamo
studiati tutti a scuola.
Sapete che l'uomo di Neandertal
non è un nostro antenato;
era un nostro cugino.
Abbiamo vissuto insieme con lui,
anche qua in Italia, in queste vallate,
proprio in queste zone;
c'erano i villaggi dei Sapiens
e i villaggi dei Neandertal.
Comunicavamo, probabilmente,
forse ci scambiavamo
addirittura le tecnologie.
Ci sono dei siti in cui, a volte,
una novità compare
nell'accampamento dei Sapiens
e poi la vedi nei Neandertal, e viceversa.
Quindi vuol dire che c'era una relazione.
La nostra storia evolutiva
ha avuto un sacco di alter ego.
Non siamo mai stati soli.
È da pochissimo tempo
che siamo soli su questo pianeta.
E in quella grotta,
gli scienziati pensavano di trovare
o Sapiens, o Neandertal, o tutti e due.
Sono andati a prendersi
un piccolo mignolo,
una falange di uno scheletro,
l'hanno portato in Germania,
hanno tirato fuori il DNA -
sapete che oggi si può fare:
non è Jurassic Park,
ma insomma si può fare, si tira fuori,
e si può vedere a quale specie appartenga.
E si è scoperto che non era
né dei Sapiens né dei Neandertal,
ma di un'altra specie ancora.
Quindi una storia
molto complicata di convivenze.
So già che vi state chiedendo
una cosa che ci chiediamo tutti,
perché l'evoluzione,
lo diceva Gould stesso,
è una storia di morte e di sesso.
E le due cose ci interessano
sempre un sacco.
Quindi, come sono finite
tutte queste specie non lo sappiamo,
quindi come si sono estinte,
il lato morte non lo sappiamo.
Si sono estinte tutte molto di recente:
e forse, so che state
già pensando anche a questo,
c'è il nostro zampino.
Quindi, un po' abbiamo contribuito
anche noi ad estinguerle;
ma non sappiamo esattamente come,
perché non è stato niente di drammatico.
Su questo siamo sicuri:
non è stato un genocidio.
Non le abbiamo estinte direttamente.
Dev'essere successo qualcosa d'altro
che ha portato al loro
regresso progressivo.
Fatto sta che, da poco tempo,
siamo rimasta l'unica
specie umana sul pianeta.
Poi c'è il versante sesso,
ed è anche questo sorprendente.
Fino a qualche mese fa,
vi avrei risposto che le specie
non potevano accoppiarsi tra di loro:
c'era una barriera genetica, pensavamo.
Ma l'ultima scoperta fatta
è che non è così.
Pensate: tutti i Sapiens non africani,
cioè quelli usciti dall'Africa
e poi rimasti fuori dall'Africa,
contengono nel loro sangue, probabilmente,
una traccia neandertaliana
dal quattro al sei percento.
Quindi nel nostro DNA, nel nostro sangue,
scorre una piccola traccia del Neandertal.
Com'è possibile questo?
L'unico modo, o per lo meno,
il modo più plausibile per spiegarlo
è che almeno in un momento,
si pensa in Medio Oriente,
per 10, 15.000 anni ci siamo accoppiati.
Abbiamo avuto accoppiamenti fertili,
quindi le due specie
si sono unite insieme.
Per poco: poi si sono separate,
una delle due si è estinta
e noi Sapiens abbiamo avuto
il sopravvento.
Però questo è un bel dogma che cade,
perché il nostro genoma non è solo nostro,
quindi non dobbiamo esserne troppo gelosi;
ma è un mantello di arlecchino,
dentro il quale ci sono tracce
addirittura di altre specie.
Non siamo soli nemmeno
dentro il nostro genoma.
Vi faccio vedere questa immagine,
perché noi siamo usciti da qui.
Questo è un altro dato recentissimo:
lo stretto di Gibuti.
Da questo piccolo passaggio
sono uscite le popolazioni dei Sapiens,
che poi, uscendo, hanno incontrato
le altre specie uscite prima:
i Neandertal; l'uomo di Denisova
che vi ho fatto vedere prima;
e poi le specie indonesiane.
Questo è un quadro riassuntivo
di tutto quello che vi ho raccontato:
noi usciamo dall'Africa;
siamo usciti più volte
da 100, 120.000 anni fa;
e uscendo incontriamo
forme viventi già esistenti,
specie umane nostre cugine.
Conviviamo, qualche volta ci accoppiamo,
e poi colonizziamo tutto il mondo.
E soltanto noi, per esempio,
siamo arrivati in Australia
e poi abbiamo colonizzato le Americhe,
perché nelle ere glaciali
il mondo era diverso da come appare qua.
C'erano degli interi continenti
che ora sono sommersi, come la Beringia,
oppure tutta questa zona qua
era percorribile via terra;
e quindi si poteva arrivare,
senza attraversare il mare,
dal Sud Africa fino all'America del Sud.
Una delle conseguenze, ovviamente,
di tutta questa storia è:
primo, che forse
dobbiamo guardare all'evoluzione
con un pochino più di umiltà,
senza pensarci come l'apice
di questa storia,
anche perché appunto
ci siamo mescolati insieme;
e la cosa interessante,
ma la dico solo in chiusura
perché non vorrei scandalizzare nessuno,
è che noi sappiamo, anche,
che gli accoppiamenti erano asimmetrici,
cioè era sempre il maschio Neanderthal
con una femmina Sapiens.
Che per noi maschietti Sapiens
è veramente sconfortante
(Risate)
perché ci siamo fatti rubare
le femmine già 40.000 anni fa,
e quindi usciamo malissimo
dall'evoluzione.
Ma la seconda conseguenza è più seria,
ed è il fatto che,
se la storia è andata così,
quelle che abbiamo sempre chiamato
"razze umane" non esistono.
Siamo una specie giovane,
veniamo fuori tutti
da un piccolissimo gruppo,
e non c'è stato il tempo
per separare le razze umane.
Quindi cancelliamo,
dal linguaggio della scienza,
il concetto di razza umana.
Grazie.
(Applausi)